what does it a car test Irvine hugged
Eisenhower explains that in an accident
children are seven times more likely to
suffer serious or fatal injuries if
they're not correctly secured the
quality of the safety features is also
important and something parents really
need to get right is the child seat
isofix is a standardized connector that
securely fastens the child seat to the
car it saves you from getting tangled up
trying to attach the seat using the
seatbelt if everything's fitted
correctly the child should suffer
minimal impact in an accident final says
that if your car doesn't have isofix
connectors the child seat can be
attached using the seat belts just make
sure the belt isn't twisted and you must
always deactivate the passenger airbag
it's off hidden file in by thousands
yeah by the activia
for many families the stressful part of
going on vacation is loading up the
trunk then adults should make sure
everyone's strapped in and ready to go
small children at least babies under 18
months should be in seats facing
backwards this supports the child's head
neck and back and provides excellent
protection and case of a head-on
collision
with older children it's important that
their heads don't stick out too far over
the top of the seat this avoids head and
neck injuries during a rear collision
always use the belt to strap the child
in and read the instructions carefully
exactly side impacts are especially
dangerous explains linehalt but modern
side airbags provide extra protection
for children and seats facing forwards
or backwards but it's important to make
sure no objects like toys or clothes are
left between the side airbag cover and
the child seat in case of a crash these
could go flying and might be very
dangerous if you can get shots already
no matter what fun the passengers are
having the driver should never get
distracted there should always be an
adult passenger to keep an eye on the
back seats and make sure the children
are safe
temperature is also a key factor keeping
the car at a constant 22 degrees Celsius
keeps your kids from getting cold and
also holds fuel consumption down but to
finish up let's take a look at how not
to do it
the child sitting on an adult's lap or
on the armrest without a seat belt
standing in front of the passenger seat
lying on the back seats
are even sitting in the trunk
ken I'm auto taking children in the car
is a big responsibility but just a few
simple steps can keep your little ones
safe on the rug
you